so no morning spoon for me but at least
I can enjoy a good breakfast to start
the day that's all they've got to offer
and depressing is that this is crazy
I've got to find some breakfast
I'm starving and cold coffee isn't going
to do it but I've heard there's an
amazing farmers market in town so lovely
little place I've heard David from
Mason's kitchen runs a food truck here
in his spare time
no deep-fried calamari I hope I saw the
lion I thought wow what you said yeah
okay brilliant I have a book more food
truck with a buddy of mine Chris a
little taste of New Mexico this is one
of my favorites right here cucumber lime
perfect 100 degrees outside that's
perfect right my goodness
wow that's delicious so what's in the
case dear thank you
delicious yeah baby that's better
but anything I've eaten in the hotel you
know that the food truck is my creative
outlet it's a place for me to at least
express my ideas without having any
borders good job guys thank you how you
feeling okay I think it's important for
you to understand the bigger picture
yeah kick in with me please Thank You
Kelly this is some of your guests I'd
like you to share your experiences why
do we start off with you first please
first impressions are important to me
and the very first thing I had to do is
sign a cleaning waiver and it just it
makes the assumption that I'm not going
to be clean that assumption was it was
just a tough first impression yes about
the point waivers are for bungee jumps
are you apparel the whole thing for me
wasn't to make you think that I didn't
think that you were clean it was I had
someone come in and throw red wine all
over the Venetian plaster and I thought
that I should charge them for that every
other guest license of one guest that is
not right you know you can't penalize
future business on the back of one idiot
it appears that there's no fun in to
what the customers gonna experience for
instance the first thing on a hot day
you want to go into the pool and we
looked out to the pool and it's right
now it's the same way it's got a lot of
leaves and it's dirty so that maybe it's
not open but how can it not be open yes
about a point but I'm pleased we were in
the lounge for dinner and when you were
singing we couldn't have a conversation
it's just not appropriate for an upscale
intimate fine dining experience I feel
like you're very focused on the
performance but you're not really
focused on your guests very interesting
so anything that goes wrong with the
restaurant when you're singing you're
too busy singing and not caring about
your guests I would pay you 100 bucks
not the same as long as you are focused
on your singing career and not on your
restaurant and hotel career my wife and
I won't be back I don't agree I have
quite a bit of people that come here to
hear music guess we back is critical
it's about turning that negativity into
something positive now I'd like to
introduce you to a very special lady
Neelu
Mohammed she is the fetus director and
the senior correspondent for the Travel
and Leisure magazine needed and gives an
insight to your state please one of the
things that we look at is whether a
hotel has a sense of place whether it's
maximizing the value that that beautiful
setting that it's in have you mentioned
the pool that's one great example of a
moment where you have a potential great
asset here that is being underutilized
and it's kind of underwhelming there's a
reason why hotel schools exist so it's
not a hobby it's a business